en tout de suite la direction de
bruxelles ou la président de la
commission européenne ue c'est la vente
de ryan s'exprime on écoute
d'armes et d'autres équipements à un
pays victime d'une attaque il s'agit
d'un tournant
monsieur morel va vous présenter cette
proposition dans un instant en parallèle
nous renforçons à nouveau les sanctions
imposées contre le kremlin et ses
collaborateurs le régime de loukachenko
nous commençons par fermer l'espace
aérien de l'union européenne pour la
russie nous proposons une interdiction
de tout avion appartenant à des russes
contre les par des russes ces appareils
ne pourront plus
survoler le territoire atterrir ou
décoller du territoire de l'union
européenne
cela s'appliquera à tout avion charter
ou autre contrôlé par une
personne russe et je tiens à être très
clairs notre espace aérien sera fermé à
tout avion russe ce qui inclut les jets
privés des oligarques
deuxièmement
autre mesure sans précédent nous allons
interdire dans l'union européenne
la machine médiatique du kremlin
rhj a tous des époux tu niques qui
appartiennent à l'état ainsi que leurs
filiales
n'auront plus l'autorisation de diffuser
leur mensonge pour justifier la guerre
de poutine est planté la graine de la
division dans notre union nous
développons donc des outils pour
interdire leur appareil de
désinformation toxiques en europe
troisièmement nous allons cibler les
autres agresseurs de cette guerre le
régime de loukachenko
le régime de loukachenko est complice de
cette attaque vicieuse contre l'ukraine
nous allons donc frapper le régime de
loukachenko avec de nouvelles sanctions
nous allons introduire des mesures à
restriction contre les secteurs les plus
importants cela permettra de supprimer
les exportation de
tabac bois acier et minéraux
nous allons également
appliquer les actes restrictions
aux exportations qui ont déjà été
imposées à la russie cela permettra
d'éviter un risque de contournement des
mesures qui ont été appliquées contre la
russie
par ailleurs nous allons imposer des
sanctions contre les habitants du
bélarus qui contribue aux efforts de
belliqueux de la russie
tout cela en plus du paquet de série
déjà présenté qu'ils étaient convenus
par un aux partenaires avec ce paquet de
sanctions deux grandes banques russes
seront exclus du système swift
nous allons également interdire les
transactions de la banque centrale russe
est gelé tous les actifs afin d'éviter à
sept banques de financer la guerre de
poutine et nous allons cibler et les
actifs des oligarques russes également
nous continuons à travailler en étroite
collaboration avec nos partenaires à
travers le monde et nous continuons à
entretenir un contact rapproché avec nos
amis ukrainiens le président les lnd qui
avec son leadership son courage la
résilience du peuple ukrainien sont tout
simplement des exemples incroyable une
source d'inspiration pour chacun d'entre
nous
nous accueillons à bras ouverts les
ukrainiens qui ont dû fuir à les bombes
de poutine et je suis fier de l'accueil
chaleureux que les européens leur ont
réservé
nous mobilisons toutes les ressources
tous les rues pour soutenir nos états
membres à l'est de l'union pourra
accueillir et prendre soin de ces
réfugiés
nous le ferons dans un esprit de
solidarité totale et sur ce je donne la
parole à monsieur morel qui va faire
sans notre sa présentation merci madame
la présidente comme vous l'avez dit
nous sommes face à une guerre de grande
ampleur directement à nos frontières
cette guerre à la frontière de l'europe
le président poutine foule du pied
l'état et l'identité d'une ukraine
souveraine et de son peuple
ce que nous observons est une simple
violation du droit international
et nous voyons que des civils et les
infrastructures sont ciblés le droit
humanitaire
est également bafoués nous voyons qu'il
ya des envois de missiles de bombes et
d'obus toutefois les forces armées
ukrainiennes sont courageuses et
repousse l'ennemi se bat avec une
résistance héroïque contre cette
invasion
nous voyons une armée qui lutte contre
l'envahisseur lamballe envahisseurs
poutine
mène une guerre qui va au delà de
l'ukraine nous devons prendre conscience
de la gravité de la situation pour nous
les européens et pour la sécurité
mondiale
cet après midi poutine a annoncé qu'il
place et les forces de dissuasion
nucléaire russe dans un état d'alerté
élevé il est important de souligner que
les forces nucléaires de la russie
sont en
systèmes statut alerte
nous nous sommes entretenus avec les
responsables du g7 et nous avons été a
accompagné par le ministre les gars qui
nous a informés des dernières évolutions
de la situation sur le terrain et du
besoin urgent de l'ukraine en
différentes choses et je leur ai répondu
vous êtes venus et la semaine dernière
nous nous avons nous avons demandé
l'exclusion du système swift qu'elle
nous avons demandé des armes nous
faisons tout ce que nous pouvons pour
soutenir l'ukraine nous sommes aux côtés
de l'ukraine
dans une heure
vais retrouver pour la quatrième fois
cette semaine les le conseil des
ministres des affaires étrangères
européens pour une réunion
extraordinaire
pour faire suivre à la demande du
ministre collègue
le ministre ukrainien des affaires
étrangères aujourd'hui je proposerai
d'utiliser les facilités européenne pour
la paix pour apporter des pourra peser
des mesures pour appliquer des mesures
d' aide d'urgence afin d'apporter du
matériel à l'armée ukrainienne et vous
rapporter du carburant des équipements
de protection et d amener du matériel
médical
un autre tabou est tombé le tabou que
l'union européenne n'apportez pas
n'offrez pas des herbes des armes en
temps de guerre eh bien nous le faisons
en effet cette guerre nécessite notre
engagement nous devons soutenir l'armée
ukrainienne
nous vivons une époque inédites
comme pendant la pandémie
et par conséquent
nous sommes confrontés à une guerre sans
précédent et cette guerre ne s'arrêtera
pas là
c'est la première fois de notre histoire
que l'union européenne apportera des
équipements les taux à un pays tiers
salle j'ai également instruit mon équipe
et l'équipe militaire de l'union
européenne de mettre en place un
mécanisme afin de coordonner les
demandes de l'armée ukrainienne afin
d'être en mesure de répondre de la
manière la plus efficace que possible
aux côtés des autres judas membres à
leurs besoins les besoins exprimés par
le ministre colbert à aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous allons apporter nous
allons également
soutenir
l'application d'un paquet de sanctions
prévues glauque et par la bande à ryan
qui ouvriront la voie à une adoption
rapide de tout de tout ces sanctions
comme madame a expliqué nous avons
annoncé des sanctions économiques fortes
l'exclusion du système swift les
sanctions sur la banque centrale et nous
allons également
ajouté des personnes des oligarques à la
liste des personnes sanctionnées nous
allons cibler l'élite du régime poutine
à qui profitent financièrement du
système nous allons également renforcer
les mesures contre le bélarus
qui
facilite et l'aso russo contre l'ukraine
avec ces mesures plus de la moitié des
réserves de la banque centrale russe
seront bloqués
de plus en plus d'états membres
annoncent également la fermeture de leur
espace aérien aux
avions russes et nous allons adopter une
approche commune décidé d'une approche
commune avec les autres ministres enfin
la désinformation car poutine ne
souhaite
simplement une conquête territoriale il
souhaite également conquérir l'esprit
des gens avec des messages toxiques des
mensonges le kremlin et ses partisans
sont engagés dans une grande campagne de
désinformation en ukraine dans notre
voisinage et au sein de l'union
européenne
et nous avons lutté contre la
désinformation nous luttons depuis 2015
avec une un groupe de travail spécifique
et une plate forme de lutte contre la
désinformation dans l'union européenne
et d'ailleurs je vous invite toutes et
tous à consulter cette plateforme
aujourd'hui nous allons encore plus loin
pour couper la
manipulation couper la désinformation
russe en interdit sans recharge ou des
et s foot ni cas ils n'auront plus droit
de diffuser leurs mensonges aujourd'hui
dans l'union européenne à nous
par ailleurs nous continuons à
travailler en étroite collaboration avec
l'ukraine afin de lutter contre les
tentatives de distorsion de la réalité
pour lutter contre la désinformation
et comme madame dhalla dit nous allons
continuer à travailler en coordination
avec le gouvernement ukrainien et les
pays voisins
et à faire tout ce qui est en notre
pouvoir pour apporter tout le soutien
dont le peuple ukrainien a besoin et
pour mettre un terme à cette guerre
insensée merci